[موسيقى]
اسرائيل جزء جديد من المنطقه بالنسبه
الينا واعتقد ان هناك اشياء عديده نعمل
عليها مع اسرائيل لدمجهم ضمن التحالف
بالاسلوب الذي تدربنا عليه في الماضي
فاعتقد اننا نحاول ان نؤسس معيار معين
ولكن الشيء الاهم هو اننا قمنا بتعيين
الفريق جرينكو بيتش لقياده القوات الجويه
الامريكيه في القياده المركزيه اعتقد ان
زياراته الحاليه تؤسس تلك العلاقه وبناء
الوفاق مع الاسرائيليين واطراف اخرى
[موسيقى]
فقد جاء الى هنا بمنصب قائد العمليات من
القياده المركزيه ولذلك فقط سبق ان تواصل
مع البعض من المنطقه الجزئيه الخاصه
باسرائيل مثيره لاننا نود التعرف على
قدراتهم ونقاط القوه التي يمكن ان يقدموها
لدول الخليج للتعرف على التهديدات
وامكانيه اندماجهم بالشكل الامثل
[موسيقى]
زرتها مؤخرا للمشاركه في مؤتمر الابتكار
من الاشياء التي نبحث عنها في ما يخص
تهديدات المختلفه هي المنظومات الجويه غير
الماهوله فهي رخيصه الثمن وسهله الصنع
ويصعب الدفاع
فهذه الروح الابتكاريه التي يمكن لدول
اخرى ان تقدمها اضافه الى نظرتهم للمشكلات
وتاثيرها مفيد جدا بالنسبه الينا قد تكون
لديهم بعض نقاط القوه او القدرات التي
يمكن ان نقدمها لدول المنطقه في زياره
لاسرائيل كانت لحضور مؤتمر الابتكار الذي
عقد في منتدى رائعا بمشاركه العديد من
الدول
[موسيقى]